reader and former director of ice tom
home and tom it's great to have you in
studio first of all to sit right across
from each other and talk about this
since you and i have had an opportunity
to do this more than a million and a
half illegal immigrants have crossed the
border and when you heard rich's report
there he's talking about the trump
administration or the bite
administration reinstating that trump
era mpp remain in mexico what's your
reaction will that help
it will help if they do it right look we
had to sue them to do that i was
actually part of that lawsuit i felt
more after davis suing this president
than i did my entire career so i worked
very closely with the state of texas
and uh we sued to make him do it then
they then they weren't doing it so the
court had to come back and tell him you
need to make this happen then he made
all the excuses that we don't have the
process in place we've got to start from
the ground up then more after dates were
filed basically tell them wait a minute
just dust off the plan we've already
done this this has already been done
dust off the plane and start small make
it work so they say they're going to do
it but let's be clear
they're they're made to do this they
don't want to do this they're still
trying to kill the program so they're
going to continue to slow roll this it
will it won't be effective because they
don't want it to be
effective they want more migrants to
cross the border this is open borders
they're going to push back to consist
they don't support it why are they doing
this you say they want this why
because in their eyes it's the future
democratic voters and their future
people you know they also overturn the
trump census rule right so they'll be
counted the next census millions of
people which is going to result in more
seats in house with democrats which
equals perpetual power in their minds
these are future democratic voters and
that's why they have open borders
there's no other reason to open the
border there's no downside on having a
secure border
it seems that national security is
really something that needs to be a
bigger part of this conversation tom in
full disclosure you and i talk often of
it i was just in panama this past week
the foreign minister erica muenas
telling congressman tony gonzalez who's
on this program earlier that some 52
known terrorist individuals crossed that
dangerous darien gap jungle where i was
and it's this pipeline tom that runs
from south america all the way to our
border in texas where you were seeing
there you can see the boat those
migrants most of them haitian they're
coming across that jungle and then
they're being taken to a little town
called las blancas and they'll go 12
straight hours on a bus directly to the
costa rican border and be led out there
to continue their journey yet this has
implications of national security
absolutely let's be clear there is no
national security
there is no homeland security without
border security that's just that's just
a common sense as i've said for months
this is a national security crisis
because when half the board patrols off
the line taking care of these large
groups that's when the cartels use those
open borders to move drugs to move gang
members and to move suspected terrorists
the daring gap for the last decade has
been a major route for non-suspected
terrorism uh terrorists to come through
there we've actually and when i was with
ici director we had agents down there
working with the panamanian government
we wrestled a couple hundred known
suspected terrorists whose who was in
the daring gap made that journey to the
endearing gap and their final
destination many of them was united
states so you had great coverage down
there and people need to understand if
there's tens of thousands of people
coming through the daring gap
known as suspected terrorists will embed
themselves in those groups
well we've got to leave the conversation
there but when i was there they had a
department of state under secretary uzra
zaya who was meeting with the panamanian
president maybe we'll see they'll try
and do something down there to stop it
before it comes up on our border tom
homan thank you for coming in studio
it's great to have you
thanks for